quarante ans jour pour jour après le 1er
février 54 l'abbé pierre a lancé
aujourd'hui un nouvel appel en faveur
des sans abri c'était au micro de rtl
qui à l'époque s'appelait radio
luxembourg portage marque maisonneuve
la communauté emmaüs du quai de la gare
à paris le cri de l'abbé pierre diffusé
à 13h à la radio ils sont tous membres
de la communauté ils ont entendu l'appel
de 54 et quarante ans plus tard il
m'écoute et me mets à me réveillant du
ac d'indifférence c'est la guerre la
guerre de défense contre la misère qui
attaquent l'univers total des sommes en
europe le savez d'où 40 millions de
personnes vivent en dessous du seuil de
la pauvreté dans les banlieues dans les
cités de nos grandes villes des
générations de jeunes sont laissés à
l'abandon sans espoir de logements sans
projet sans avenir
est ce qu'il peut attendre des
catastrophes bien visibles bien filmé
pour enfin se mobiliser car 5 millions
de français n'ont pas un logement décent
selon l'abbé pierre cela fait 40 ans que
l'état d'urgence dure que le provisoire
demeure et pendant ce temps que fait
nuit il ya désormais des pins en plein
paris quarante ans ont passé et la
misère est resté l'abbé pierre crie
toujours avec ce qu'il lui reste de voix
parfois on assiège pour se donner bonne
conscience ce petit homme malade a
décidé d'utiliser ses dernières forces
pour que sa voix porte encore pour
qu'elle perce enfin le mur épais de
l'indifférence
et ce soir françois mitterrand rendu
officiellement hommage au courage et à
la persévérance de l'abbé pierre ce
n'est pas franchement le point de vue du
numéro 2 du fonds m